port is going to cost white at least one  rook maybe even more  how is she gonna keep control though  okay she goes for it now  winning i think still but  she's made it maybe less simple  now the black rook not ideally placed  she has to be a bit careful now bring  the black knight back though  bring the black knight back it's offside  it could get attacked it's unprotected  square yeah definitely  and she does that and that should be  game set a match  okay one last threat for white white was  threatening to go up to the top of the  board with this rook and check but no  more checks it's time to start marching  the black pawns the black pawn will be a  distraction it will deflect away the  white rook white's pawn will drop and  has way given up  there we go  wow  what a performance today by ju when jun  she beats her fellow chinese player wei  and she's had an incredible day